qui parmi vous se trouve beau
allez-y lever la main qui parmi vous ne
se trouve pas beau lever la main aussi
bon plein kanaker hésiter sur la réponse
et d'autres qu'on me pas l'air de savoir
s'ils se trouve ou non
pour ma part ma vision de la beauté a
beaucoup évolué et ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je vous trouve tous très
beaux quand j'étais ado je rêvé de
ressembler à une star
les spice girls fasciné vêtements
colorés et tape-à-l'oeil chaussures à
talons vertigineux coiffure impeccable
maquillage à outrance strass paillettes
la totale rien n'était laissé au hasard
tout me semble si parfait et c'est
justement ce que je cherchais mois la
perfection bon il faut dire pour ça que
j'étais au moins aussi organiser qu'un
pilote qui procéderaient à l'ultime
vérification à le décollage petit
flashback nous voilà projetés 14 ans
plus tôt dans ma chambre d'ado il est 6
heures mon réveil sonne nous sommes à un
chemin de croix avant le début des cours
j'ai clairement plus une minute à perdre
si je veux arriver au collège l'esprit
tranquille
alors c'est parti meteo consult et la
veille il va faire beau aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire que je peux enfin m ma
toute nouvelle jupe elle est bleue elle
est magnifique bien tant que je la mets
avec quoi et la panique je vois défiler
mille et une possibilités de tenues dans
ma tête ça me donne le tournis bon je
teste un grand pour les essayages
je vais tout doucement dans le couloir
cherché mais je ne sais combien de
paires de chaussures que j'aligne devant
le miroir que je classe par style par
couleur par auteur par préférence
l'armoire j'attrape quatre ou cinq
vêtements qui tenait tout juste un
équilibre on ne sait pas trop comment
ai-je et c est après x aller retour
devant le miroir avec un mot puis un
autre canton des talons des baskets
voilà qu'un beau tissu pailleté me fait
de l'oeil est là mais j'y crois pas
c'est exactement le même bloc que celui
de ma jupe seaux d'eau
bon je vous laisse imaginer l'étape
accessoires avec ces rappels de couleurs
la coiffure où chaque mèche est à sa
place
le maquillage est impossible de sortir
sans maquillage
j'allais oublier le vernis ce cher
vernis que j'enlève et que je remets
chaque matin de la couleur exacte et je
dis qu'est exact de ma tenue est pas un
demi ton plus clair au plus foncé 1
sinon c'est toute ma journée qui est
gâchée oula oula
il est 8 heures 35 là il va falloir y
aller la ultime défilé devant le miroir
pas mal
avec quelques heures de plus ça aurait
été parfait mais un petit ça ira pour
aujourd'hui
pourquoi il ya toujours cette telle
satisfaction
je peux quand même pas faire plus que ça
me voilà cela dehors
au fond j'ai envie de vivre avec un
miroir j'ai en face de moi pour
m'assurer que tout est à sa place quand
rien ne dépasse
et que ma vitrine est à la hauteur de ce
que je veux envoyer mais ça n'est pas
possible alors je sors mon miroir de
poche et je vérifie
je vérifie je vérifier encore et je
revérifie pourquoi je suis si accro au
détail pourquoi tout est si compliqué
dans ma tête
j'arrive au collège est elle une vedette
qui descendraient le tapis rouge au
festival de cannes
j'avance de ne pas assurer la tête haute
le sourire aux lèvres
parfait l'illusion est là tout le monde
ne me pense sur deux - extravertie alors
qu'en réalité s'il savait bon je vous
laisse deviner au moment de
l'orientation professionnelle vers quoi
je suis allé allez je vous écoute et ben
oui l'esthétique
changement de décor institut de beauté
mais voilà maintenant baignant dans tout
un tas de crem produits parfums jean
mais l'idée vitrine mais non plus la
mienne cette fois ci celle des autres
ici des clients viennent me voir des
hommes des femmes attendent mes conseils
mes soins mon regard
pour moi qui avais l'habitude d'ériger
un mur de maquillage entre les autres et
moi mais voilà obligée de m'occuper de
l'autre parce que pour l'autre c'est
bien plus qu'un simple rendez vous chez
l'esthéticienne c'est son moment sacré
c'est comme si tout d'un coup je
réalisais les points communs entre eux
et moi que tous les efforts que je
faisais pour embellir ma vitrine
mon image mon apparence n'était
peut-être pas si léger anodin que ça
aucun nom qu'est ce qui fait que cette
jeune femme si belle si coquette arrive
à l'institut tête baissée et passe toute
la séance à me demander comment je la
trouve merkel se voit pas elle est
sublime
la montagne paris et entre glacée et je
dois passer toute la séance à la
rassurer et la rassurer pour petit à
petit la voir s'ouvrir peu un peu mes
certitudes s'effrite 1
c'est vraiment le moment de la prise de
conscience
et si nous étions bien plus que nos
corps et si nous étions bien plus que
des vitrines aux façades différentes
rester en surface me deviennent
désormais impossible ma vision plate
illusoire superficiel et dénuée de sens
de la beauté c'est comme évaporée
ma place n'est plus en vitrine mais au
coeur de l'humain ça bouillonne dans ma
tête ça pétille dans mon coeur un vent
libérateur
nouveau changement de décor
mais voilà maintenant en milieu
hospitalier et plus particulièrement en
cancérologie contexte ambiance certes
bien plus différents que précédemment
mais étrangement je me sens bien très
bien je me sens à ma place je suis
désormais socio esthéticienne je vous
entends de la socio quoi socio
esthéticienne pour vous expliquer avec
moi ni piqûre ni perfusion ni douleur ni
traitement ni médicament
c'est un petit peu la parenthèse de
douceur de réconfort pour tous ceux qui
traversent cette tornade qui est la
maladie maladie
voilà un mot qui impressionne parce que
deux maladies découlent les traitements
des traitements découlent les effets
secondaires perte des cheveux décide des
sourcils ongles qui noircissent et qui
tombe déshydratation de la peau terne
grisâtre et puis fatigue mal-être
douleur mutilation impuissance solitude
la liste est longue et elle est d'autant
plus longue que la maladie à ce drôle de
pouvoir que de faire remonter à la
surface de faire ressortir et de faire
défiler tous ceux qui étaient enfouis
jusque là les événements marquants les
douleurs accumulé les angoisses les
blessures du passé tout ressort donc
comment continuer à avancer dans cette
tornade
comment garder le cap
quand tout d'un coup l'estimé la
confiance en soi s'envole le reflet du
miroir deviennent insupportables
le regard des autres violent aussi là et
ma mission
ma raison d'agir et ma passion réveiller
cette étincelle deux devis de beauté
profonde que je perçois au fond de
chaque personne de chaque regard c'est
comme si j'étais connecté cette
étincelle est là et elle demande qu'à
être ravivée et pour ça j'ai plusieurs
outils ça peut être un soin du visage
soins des mains pour pallier la
déshydratation des traitements un
massage un maquillage pour apprendre à
dessiner les cils et sourcils une sophro
relaxation une réflexologie plantaire
j'ai pas vraiment de limite quant au
contenu de mes séances chaque personne
est différente
donc j'ai à coeur de ne jamais rien
figer ne jamais rien programmé à
l'avance tout est possible parce que
tout se passe dans l'instant avec pour
seul objectif le mieux être mais avant
tout soin corporel ou relaxant je débute
toujours mes séances par une simple et
toute petite question comment ça va
lui pour bifurquer vers soi même on
commence à 20 qui a ce don de fendiller
les carapaces les masques les voiles
qu'on a pu se mettre pour aller toucher
l'essentiel le coeur à ce coeur quand on
a passé toute sa vie à rester en surface
quand on sait depuis si longtemps
oubliée on a du mal à l'écouté
c'est donc le moment des confidences le
moment de faire un point
un bilan sur soi sur sa vie et si
justement la maladie était cette
sonnette d'alarmé qui me permet de
m'écouter
cette sonnette d'alarmé qui permet de se
réveiller de se reconnecter à soi-même
savez platon le disais il ya 2500 ans
on ne peut pas chercher à guérir le
corps sans chercher à guérir l'âme bien
j'ai compris que s'acharnait à soigner
l'enveloppé uniquement lé enveloppe le
corps n'a pas de sens
en fait c'est un peu comme au cinéma
vous regardez un film et tout d'un coup
l'image se brouille
est-ce que vous pensez que la solution
est de changer l'écran
ou est-ce qu'il faut remonter au niveau
du projecteur pour voir et comprendre ce
qui se passe bien en saisissant que le
corps n'est que cette projection
extérieure de tout ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
tout devient différent et à partir de ce
moment là mon métier ma pratique mes
soins prennent une tout autre dimension
une dimension plus subtil plus sensible
plus empathique
je ne m'adresse plus aux patients mais
je m'adresse à lui-même je ne touche
plus que le corps mais je touche la
beauté au coeur du corps j'espère que
maintenant vous pourrez voir l'autre
tels que j'ai appris à le voir et que
vous pourrez vous voir tel que je vous
vois dans votre beauté une beauté bien
plus profonde de bien plus durable que
votre seule façade
alors je vous repose la question qui
parmi vous se sent beau
[Applaudissements]